they don't care about the country at all
and that's you know that's kind of their
prerogative but I do I'm going to ever
so softly call out Tucker with the hopes
of of bringing a little healing to this
thing but here is Tucker going after uh
Ben Shapiro this is just a couple days
ago I did think it showed like the level
of not just corruption which I knew but
of like emotional instability and crazy
I mean there are people and I sto
reading any of it but there are people
on the right who have spent the last two
months every single day focused on a
conflict in a foreign country as our own
country becomes dangerously unstable on
the brink of financial collapse with
tens of millions of people who shouldn't
be here in the country we don't know
their identities or the purpose of their
being here like stuff that's could
destroy the country for real and make it
impossible for my kids to live here
they've said nothing about that and
they're focused with laser intensity on
foreign conflicts and I'm like at some
point I've got four kids if I'm so
caught up in the problems of my
neighbor's children and completely
ignoring my own children as they get
addicted to drugs and kill
themselves you know I'm not against
helping my neighbor kids but clearly I
don't love my kids I mean that's that's
you know that's the only logical
conclusion and they don't care about the
country at all and that's you know
that's kind of their prerogative but I
do because I have no choice because I'm
from here my family's been here hundreds
of years I plan to stay here like I I'm
shocked by how little they care about
the country and including the person you
mentioned and I I can't imagine how
someone like that could get an audience
of people who claimed about care about
America cuz he doesn't obviously right
right okay I'm sorry I'm sorry that is
just a seriously low IQ take and and
really lwh hanging fruit and dishonest
by Tucker so Tucker if you're watching
this and maybe I'll send you this video
myself I'll text it to you uh you you
got to do a little bit better than that
the idea that Ben Shapiro does not care
about America nor has been like basic
basically the number one conservative
voice in alt media for the last decade
basically is crazy yes Ben has spent an
awful lot of time over the last three
months talking about Israel and many
people have by the way Tucker Mr America
First Tucker um there are American
hostages still Americans were killed and
there still are American hostages being
held by Hamas in Gaza right now should
Americans not care about that also as
I've said many times you should be able
to walk and chew what have I done on
this show for the last three months have
I talked about what's going on in Israel
an awful lot of course but every single
day do I talk about the Border do I talk
about the fenel do I talk about
immigration and the drugs and all of the
stuff that's happening and I have no
doubt that Ben is doing that too so I
think in a in a very cynical cynical
move there unfortunately what Tucker is
trying to do is he's going Ben is my
competition now I building out the
Tucker Carlson Network who who is our
competition well Fox is our competition
and the daily wire is our competition
and say the blaze is our competition and
I'm going to go out and and take out Ben
and it's just not right and it's not
good and I would say beyond anything
else beyond anything else we have a much
bigger problem it is the problem that I
have spent the first 52 minutes of this
show talking about and if we're going to
make this about a personal beef or
because we have our own business
decisions that are that are going to
take precedence over the importance of
the country then we are effed already
Beyond imagination that's exactly where
we will
be